there's a lot of questions this looks
like some sort of super hard interview
for some
things i hope you then expect me to have
answers for
all of them
i'm here with professor anil seth of
neuroscience at the university of sussex
there aren't many people who are brave
enough to tackle consciousness
scientifically maybe there's
maybe there's 1 000 people and
there's maybe five percent of that are
paragons in the field so that's like 50
people i'd say and i would
include anil seth in that i'm super
excited to speak with him if you look up
his talk on ted i believe it's one of
the most viewed that we hallucinate
realities
you might want to view that before
watching this to get a an overview of
seth point of views
i'm also here with faraz who has a
background in neuroscience
and medical science a master's in it
actually medical science and i thought
it'd be great to have faraz tag along
this is going to be somewhat
free-flowing because me and fraz aren't
communicating with each other off-screen
in some way
so at points he might interject and it
might overlap with mine but that's fine
we'll just take it as it goes
welcome thank you professor thank oh
thank you kurt and for us it's a
pleasure to be here
so professor what are you currently
working on and how did you get
interested
in the field of consciousness so
well two different things i mean
consciousness for me has always been
interesting it's one of those questions
i think that
pretty much everyone is interested in at
some point in their lives certainly when
you're a kid it's just one of these
things these big mysteries
how does it fit into our picture of the
universe
how does it depend on the brain what
does it mean to be
me what happens when i die and all these
sort of big questions
are things that most of us wonder about
and then usually grow out of and
and do something more normal with with
life
so i've just been lucky enough to never
have been forced to grow out of these
these questions but of course that
doesn't mean that every day is like
12 hours a day just trying to answer
this
big spooky mystery about consciousness
in fact
day to day working in this area working
in this part of science translates into
a whole variety of different things that
are related
more or less directly to this big
question so just for example today we've
been
talking with my people from my research
group and colleagues
about various things like how do we
mathematically get a grip on
an emergent property people often talk
about consciousness as being
emergent from the brain somehow but what
does that mean mathematically
that's one thing another thing we were
looking at developing
uh computer simulations of different
kinds of hallucinations to
get a better grip on how different kinds
of visual hallucinations differ
and what the underlying mechanisms in
the brain
might be and then you know just before
this
this meeting i was with a phd student at
the very early stages
trying to develop new kinds of
experiments to
understand a difference between what we
might call
gist perception you know if you just see
a scene very quickly you can usually
tell that it's a landscape or it's
some very very basic features
of perception come out very quickly but
others require a bit longer to figure
out oh am i looking at this person or
that person or is it a car
or what's what are the details going on
so i'm very interested in
thinking about how to explain these
differences in visual perception
so just to say there's just an awful lot
of different um
different specific questions that we can
ask
when we're trying to understand more
about consciousness
is it cool if we get some definitions
out of the way yeah i think it's always
a good place to start
right phenomenology the way that you use
it
i assume it's different than the
philosophical doctrine of phenomenology
which is
cereals heidegger's and then there's
particle phenomenology
and i'm unclear when you say
phenomenology exactly what do you mean
well i mean i must admit i play a little
fast and loose with with the definitions
um and it's but the way i mean it is
probably quite close to the
the philosophical phenomenology of
facile and pontian and people like that
really it's just for me a way of drawing
attention
to the properties of experience
so if we talk about let's say visual
perception so perception here is
how my brain interprets visual sensory
data to form representations of the the
world outside
and you can think of that as having uh
like a functional
aspect so what does perceiving things
visually allow me to do
how do i behave with respect to visual
information but there's also
a phenomenological aspect there's how
visual experience is seen
you know the experience of redness is
different from the experience of let's
say an object in vision an object seems
to have a back even though i can't see
the back there's a phenomenology of
object hood
there's a phenomenology of spatiality
all my visual experiences
have a spatial character things
organized in space in a way that let's
say smell doesn't
doesn't have so much um
emotions would be have a very different
kind of phenomenology
and emotion feels different from any
kind of visual experience
so i use phenomenology just as a way of
thinking about what a science of
consciousness
should explain what i think a scientific
conscious should explain
are phenomenological properties
properties of
experience why redness is the way it is
in our experience and is different from
an emotion or is different from a smell
or a memory
that's what i mean by phenomenology and
when you say explain
part of the problem with consciousness
or at least people who are
less scientifically minded who are
disinclined to believe that
consciousness can be studied
materialistically i think part
of the issue is what it means to explain
consciousness what it means to explain
any phenomenon
so when you say we're trying to get an
account of consciousness
do you just mean correlates it's a very
good question i think there's a lot of
ambiguity and confusion about what
explanation means i mean whole books
have been written about what explanation
means
in science there's a beautiful book by
carl craver called explanation in
neuroscience what do you think
anything in neuroscience what does it
what does it mean to have an explanation
of it
um the way i think about it is
is an explanation in consciousness
science
does not have to solve the whole problem
of
that we come up with this intuitive
eureka moment about now i understand
how the the electrochemical pate
inside my skull gives rise to the
redness of red i
don't that's that's would be would be
nice but we can have explanations that
are relevant without
that kind of big ticket prize
so by explanation i mean more than
correlation and that's key so
so it's already a relatively standard
method
in neuroscience to look at the brain
and see what changes in the brain as
different aspects of consciousness
change
what happens in the brain when you fall
asleep or when you go into general
anesthesia
or what happens in the brain when you
consciously perceive
a scene versus you still respond to it
but you know you're not conscious of
it so this is a standard method which is
looking for the neural correlates of
consciousness
but just finding correlations is
is not sufficient for explanations
correlations provide constraints on
explanations but they don't
provide explanations themselves to
explain something
what you want to have is is in some way
the correlation is no longer arbitrary
you want to have a sense that ah yeah i
see why that correlation obtains
because it explains something about
the thing it correlates with
so which which for me means that
the right way to think about this in
terms of the brain and consciousness is
not going to be so much
this part of the brain is correlated
with conjugations in this part isn't
it's going to be at a sort of
intermediate level consciousness
correlates with
this kind of process these kinds of
dynamics in the brain because they have
similar properties
that the conscious experience has so we
need a more
kind of finessed bridge between what's
happening in the brain and what's
happening in experience
and if i can come up with something in
the brain that
tells me you're like oh that's that's
why consciousness in this case is the
way it is and not some other way
then that's an explanation uh
in science in general we judge the
success of science
a scientific field usually if it can
explain something if it can predict when
things are going to happen and if you
can control those things explanation
prediction and control
are good criteria for the success of
science and i think we should apply
those same criteria
in this case too this doesn't mean that
it has to be intuitive quantum physics
is extremely counterintuitive but in
terms of explaining phenomena predicting
and controlling it's extremely good
so this leaves open that we might come
up with a good theory of consciousness
and it might do the job of explanation
prediction and control
but we might never get the feeling that
like oh yeah that's right
now it all makes sense this might not
happen don't know yet
let's take quantum mechanics as an
example
the way that i view it is it's more
instrumental
people who are studying quantum physics
they're hesitant to
say that it's an explanation they're
more i have to say it's a
model and it provides some predictions
and it's an operationalist approach
some people might take a more
philosophical bend and say you know this
is an explanation but
truly truly i don't it's difficult to be
a scientist and not be an
instrumentalist
and if you're an instrumentalist you're
not
it depends on what you mean by explain
like is the fact that you can write
equations that predict a certain number
and then you find it in the data does
that mean that you've explained it
well well i don't know i don't know if
that matches what people
consider to be an explanation but
explanation is a different it's a tricky
like you said it's a tricky word to
define
okay now how's this related to the real
problem you mentioned that there's a
hard problem there's
the easy problem and then there's the
real problem that's your
that's your anti so i'm curious is what
you just described the real problem and
how does that delineate from the heart
problem
yeah that's basically it um so again
this is a little bit fast and loose with
these terms as they're used in
philosophy so the heart problem has
has been one of the classic go-to's in
people thinking about consciousness from
a philosophical or neuroscientific
perspective
it's ju it's uh due primarily to david
chalmers
and the australian philosopher and he
describes the heart problem of
consciousness
it's this metaphysical problem really
it's it's the idea that
even if we had a complete description of
how the brain as a mechanism worked
how it transformed sensory signals
into actions into our behavior
um if we understood everything about the
brain as a
as a physical chemical mechanism there
would still be
a mystery about why and how any of that
activity
should give rise to a conscious
experience
very broadly why is consciousness part
of our universe
at all how does it relate to the
operation of physical stuff
that's that's the hard problem and
it is a very metaphysically loaded
problem
it's it's it's really a question about
the capabilities and limitations of
physical explanations
explanations in terms of mechanisms um
and it articulates
the intuition that consciousness is
somehow
beyond the limits of physicalist and
mechanistic explanation
now there's all this debate in
philosophy neuroscience about whether
the heart problem
exists whether it's an illusion uh or
whether it can in fact be solved
i put my cards on the table will want to
remain agnostic about that
i'm not sure whether the hard problem is
a real problem
that can or cannot be solved
but what i do think is that
we can still ask questions about
consciousness without
sweeping it and under the carpet
entirely so the easy problems
are again in chalmers distinction these
are the problems that
don't really appeal to consciousness at
all they're
questions about how the brain works as a
mechanism
how it can explain perception sure but
any kind of perception
action attention behavior language
but we can answer all the easy questions
without
referring to consciousness now there's
i think an enormously rich middle ground
which is to
appreciate that conscious experiences
exist let's assume that they do and
and we have experiences of color of
shape of
of emotion all sorts of things
and we can start to
try to explain the properties of these
conscious experiences
in terms of mechanisms this is exactly
what we were talking about can i explain
why a visual experience is the way it is
and is different from let's say
an emotional experience in terms of
brain mechanisms
and if i can do that i think i'm making
progress on the
scientific explanations of consciousness
even if i'm not going directly after the
heart problem
now other people have expressed pretty
similar ideas charles himself
called the this approach something like
the mapping problem how to build
non-arbitrary correlations between
things in the brain
and things in the world of our
experience other people have talked
about
neurophenomenology this goes back to
francisco varela in particular
it's just pretty much the same thing
again how do we
link things happening in the brain to
things happening
in in our experience so there's a
tradition of of thinking
this way do you see that the okay
for us yeah sorry i just wanted to talk
about the role of perception in all this
because
i find the way you have described in the
past the perceptions
relationship with reality quite
fascinating
you have previously said before that
famously in a way you have said that
normal perception is controlled
hallucinations
now this idea of hallucination or
illusion i suppose first of all do you
do you distinguish between these two
words hallucination and illusion or
can we use them interchangeably uh maybe
you can answer this and then i have a
follow-up question to this
sure i mean well let me first say that
this is i think it's a lovely phrase uh
perception is controlled hallucination i
did certainly didn't come up with it i
heard it from
one of my mentors chris frith who heard
it somewhere
else and and actually a few of us just
we tried to
find out the proper origin of it
and i've never been able to sort of
there's this legendary seminar
ucsd sometime in 1990 uh
which people refer to but it was never
recorded and it's just
so who knows um anyway the phrase does
the rounds but i think it's a it's a
good phrase
and we'll get on to hallucinations in
more detail i'm sure in a bit
i not sure i would
use it interchangeably with with
illusion illusion i think is a very
problematic word
too because illusion sort of implies
that there
is in the context perception that there
is a non-illusory perception that
there's
such a thing one might call veridical
perception which is the sort of we're
seeing the world
as it really is and when we're
hallucinating or experiencing an
illusion
then we're not seeing the world as it
really is
but my view on this is we never see the
world
as it really is everything that we
perceive is a
is or consciously experienced in our
perceptual
work is a construction that's only
indirectly related
to what's actually there uh
it's just that the degree to which these
perceptions
are constrained by what's actually there
differs so i think illusion for me and
i'm thinking about this now really for
the first time
how i would distinguish it illusion is
probably a very systematic relationship
between what's there and what we
perceive that is not
necessarily maladaptive
it can often be just useful it's sort of
a quirk of the visual system where a
normal way of constructing our
perceptions is
revealed to be quirky in some way
and then hallucination is something a
little bit more unusual hallucination
usually means
that i'm having an experience that
you're not
or that other people aren't and it is no
longer
adapted in that same way no longer
necessarily so useful
but i wouldn't say it's a hard and hard
and fast distinction that there
if you look at for instance if we
look at fluffy clouds and see faces and
clouds then this is probably something
many of us do and you know you could
equally call that an
illusion or a hallucination and
strictly the word for that from the
greek term paradolia
seeing patterns and things so i think
there's
yeah interesting sort of landscape of
these terms
right and then to follow up to this idea
i mean
the general population might think that
for example illusions are
in a way negative limitations that might
prevent us from
reaching the supposedly noble goal of
for example searching
for the truth let's say right but um you
know you and
others such as let's say donald huffman
you've brilliantly
argued that illusions are actually could
be in a way a gift
for example in your talk about
consciousness you bring up the
adolescence checkerboard illusion
phenomenon and in a way
my my question with this would be that
if we have pragmatically evolved
in a way not to experience reality in
its true form
you know it's about fitness in a lot of
ways from an evolutionary perspective
and are better off if truth is in a way
evolutionarily or
perceptively driven toward extinction
then why should we want to get to the
root of reality
as a whole isn't ignorance bliss
in this specific case i mean there's a
lot of a lot of loaded phrases there
about about
truth and the of course truth matters
and that there are things that we can't
perceive which make a huge difference to
us you know if we could perceive
coronavirus particles i'm sure people
would be much more willing to wear masks
um and if you go and jump in front of a
bus
whether or not you're looking at it it's
going to hurt
so i'm i'm certainly not being
anti-realist about this
there's a real world out there we don't
know quite what it is
best to ask a physicist for that you
know what the ultimate nature of reality
is
but it's certainly true that whatever it
is is not we don't have and can never
have direct access to it
through perception and this is a very
old point emmanuel kant i think
says it plato said it but kant
especially talked about the pneumonian
that the sort of the external objective
reality that's forever hidden behind a
sensory veil so in a sense it's an
elusive goal to think that we could ever
perceive the true world in the sense of
having direct perceptual access to
physical reality but what we perceive is
constrained by that reality that's what
perception is all about it's a way of
constructing a world for us
that is usefully constrained by
whatever's really out there and
as you said and you know as don hoffman
has said a whole bunch of people have
said this really that
as soon as you appreciate that our
perceptual experience is not
a direct reflection of an external
objective reality
then it's quite easy to to think that
well what we perceive
is going to be tuned by evolution
to what best keeps us alive and i think
there's there's a really deep truth to
that
and you can think about it in one of the
very simple examples like color
we experience colors as usually we
experience them as really existing
properties of objects in the world color
seems to be a property of an external
objective reality but
we know that it isn't and we don't even
need neuroscience for that i mean newton
has shown
that color is is not a thing
in the physical universe it's there's
this whole continuous spectrums any part
of it that
we were able to that can shape our
experience at all
uh you know we create this universe of
colors from
the fact that our eyes are responsive to
roughly three different wavelengths
but we see way more than three colors
which
for me is fascinating because in one
sense we are perceiving
much less than what's actually out there
because we don't
experience x-rays or infrared or
ultraviolet
at all but in another sense we're
experiencing
much more than what's out there because
we create a universe of colors just from
combinations of three
wavelengths and the brain does this
because colors are very useful
to guide our interaction with the world
they're a way for the brain in this case
to keep track of surfaces when lighting
conditions change
and to what and to distinguish between
different kinds of surfaces it's very
very useful thing
but the brains have figured out what to
do
so i don't think of it as in this case
it's not like
we should the goal should be to
not experience colors anymore and
experience just those three wavelengths
of light i mean no
even though that's closer to objective
reality in some way
that seems like an odd goal to have i
think you know the
the interesting thing is just to
understand much more about this relation
how do we construct the universe of
color from a very limited
sampling of physical reality and why
is that a useful thing for the organism
to do
i mean one example that comes to my mind
regarding this was
um the idea that for example you have an
organism that is
uh it might be tuned to fitness and in
terms of
um understanding small and large
quantities of some resource as let's say
one color let's say red
and then anything that is in the middle
adds another color
so for that specific organism it doesn't
really matter whether
that resource is in a large or small
quantity that's why it sees it as
the same color and what matters is
whether it's it's in the
exact amount that the organism needs so
you know in a way evolutionarily the
organism evolves
to not distinguish between small and
large
amount of a quantity but
and and that leads to evolution in a way
hiding the the truth that is that is
behind it so
that that idea just yeah there's
something right about that and you know
i know
various people don often as well uses
this idea of the
the metaphor of the desktop right we
the the desktop on your computer is
useful because
it hides all the stuff going on in the
operating system
that is not useful for the user of the
computer to see we just want to
drag a file into a folder and
be and be unaware of what's actually
happening to make that happen
and so indeed i think there's every
reason to think that perceptual systems
are also built that way
let's take this hofmannian argument a
little further
so the argument is that there's no
relationship between or there's little
relationship between truth and fitness
and we're tuned for fitness given that
we're not seeing reality or at least we
can't claim to
now given that how can we ever make any
claim that there is an objective world
or what the characteristics of this
objective world
is like now you made a claim in one of
your talks
about misperceiving yourself that some
mental disorders can be
seen as you have the wrong idea about
yourself how can you have a wrong
idea that to me implies objective but
it's difficult to know the objective
without making reference to adaptiveness
okay so i think um i don't think
anybody's saying there's no relationship
between
truth and fitness or perception it's
just not they're not they're not the
same thing
so uh but there's gonna be some overlap
like if my
if my perceptual system reliably
represents things as far away when
they're close
and i try and cross the road i'm gonna
get run over
and that's that's and so that's
that's not a good way for perceptual
system to be organized so that there is
a
there is a systematic constraint between
what's out there and what i perceive
yeah i'm not sure if that's true now let
me
let me just okay but because there are
ways that you can form
graphs there's something called quantum
graphs i believe it's used in loop
quantum gravity
but regardless where you can represent
what's far as close and what's closest
far
and this actually hoffman does make this
argument that there is virtually no
relationship between truth and fitness
one of the ways he does it i have my
objections and anyone who's listening
can watch the podcast
one of the ways that he does this is by
saying let's imagine that the universe
that the objective world has some
property of structure let's say it's a
group structure let's say it's a
partially ordered set whatever it may be
then let's imagine the totality of the
ways that you can perceive
you find that as the complexity of the
system increases the
amount that conforms with reality now in
this example i gave
is a group or a partially ordered set
but there are various other structures
that the amount of ways that you can
form with reality divided by the total
amount of ways you can experience it
goes to zero
so he may argue no he's not here and i
could also be
misrepresenting him but he may argue
that
there is virtually zero relationship
between what's out there and how we
perceive it
and in fact okay sorry please
i mean again we probably would need him
to
to see exactly where he's planning his
flag and
but but i think i still suspect a slight
confusion here because
um i would
i would also i'm also of the view that
and we've said this earlier that
i can never perceive what is actually
there
that the nature of the physical
universe is humane there is one
which is still up for grabs right
that is something that is not directly
accessible can never be directly
perceptual mechanisms just don't
don't get that that's not what they can
do so in that sense
there will always be a gap between our
perception and what is there
however precisely because
our perceptual mechanisms have been
shaped by evolution
they will have been shaped so as to be
adaptively constrained
by the regularities in the physical
universe that are important for our
survival
which is precisely why if i'm crossing
the road
i will see things as far away when they
are far away
and as close by when they're close by
and the other the other thing useful
distinction here i think goes back again
in philosophy to
to look and the british empiricists who
who distinguished between primary and
secondary qualities
and a primary quality for lock is
something that
exists independently of a mind or of an
observer
so something like having solidity
and moving are properties that exist
independently of a mind or an observer
which is why
if i stand in front of a non-rushing bus
it's not going to go well
but then there are other properties like
color
um which are for lock secondary
qualities because
color requires the interaction between
an observer or a mind
and a physical universe
you know suzanne also talked about this
he said color is the place where the
brain and the universe meet
and so there's at least two ways of
thinking about the kinds of
things that are two ways of
a way of partitioning our ontology and
yeah and they they're both
in but in neither case is our experience
identical to whatever its hidden causes
are in the world
whether it's a primary quality or a
secondary quality we're always
constructing
on the basis of those qualities or
properties we're constructing our
experience
it's just that for a primary
property for a primary thing like
solidity
it's gonna exist whether we are
conscious of it or not
and but our perceptual mechanism will
still be constrained by it
you know we will we a well-designed
perceptual system
will be constrained in ways that
makes us behave appropriately
to these things right i get i'm i don't
want to meet
i don't want to remain stuck on this but
i guess my
objection is the notion of fartness and
nearness is dependent on space
and space-time itself
this is something donald hoffman likes
to reference there's a physicist named
nima armani hamed i believe but many
physicists in
almost every single physicist believes
that space-time is not fundamental which
means that location and just
you may say that well we're constrained
constrained is not the same as and you
you're definitely admitting
that there's not a one-to-one
relationship between reality and then
how we perceive it
but then even in these examples of
solidity well
what's solid in quantum mechanics where
the wave function spreads to the
universe
sure but there's something yeah okay but
um
firstly i think actually you bring up a
very interesting point
um we're getting very deep into the
wheats here but for me one of the most
interesting things about this way of
thinking about perception
is how far you can take it um and
uh so for instance yeah i can i can
perceive a color as and i can understand
the perception of a colored surface in
terms of an
invariance in how a surface reflects
light
and under different lighting conditions
and so on but then
what about what you might call the
deeper structure of perceptual
experience i mentioned this right the
beginning as well the fact that visual
experience is spatial that we overall
tend to
experience the world in this three plus
one dimensional way in three spatial
dimensions in one time dimension
how is that can we understand that as
constructed in the same way that we
would understand the experience of color
as being constructed
you know is our brain generating
this this architecture of experts
right through the same principles um
because yeah from a more physics-based
perspective you might say
well actually this three plus
one-dimensional
picture is not the most accurate picture
of of the physical universe and we could
argue and i would not have
an expert view about what is but you
know i know there are many options out
there
even relativity tells you that the three
plus one distinction is
is not as as solid as our perceptual
world would lead us to to imagine and
then of course you've got string theory
and also
block universes and all sorts of stuff
um
but in a sense you can you can be
agnostic about what that
ultimate reality is if there is such a
thing and still ask the question
okay so what's constructing how do we
experience time and space not just
objects within time and space
and i think for me that's that's a
really
exciting direction to push this kind of
research
speaking of the perception of time i
remember you said
this is obviously known that the more
adrenaline you have in your system
let's say it peaks you feel like time
has slowed down
well i wasn't sure i said that i mean
that you certainly there there's just
this kind of
popular assumption about um
time slowing down under various sorts of
high arousal situations
right and actually time here is
something that i've
been working on just for the last uh
four years or so and it's really due to
i had this uh one of my colleagues
warrick roseboom an australian
cognitive scientists to join the group
in 2015
and brought a deep interest in a wealth
of expertise on time perception so
he's been leading our work there and
uh one of the
so one of the i think really fascinating
lines of argument
that he's making and i i agree with him
it seems right is that
um is to push back against this idea
that we
experience time in virtue of having a
little clock inside the head
a lot of work in this area
boils down to an assumption like that
that that there's time
unfolds in the world and
certainly when we when we're making
judgments about time
we often get it wrong if there's if we
measure an objective duration
and then we ask people how long that
duration was
people can be wrong about it and they're
systematically wrong
in the same way they're systematically
wrong about
many other things in perception um
and you know for instance there's
there's a a very general
law in perceptual psychophysics where
people
are biased towards the mean of the
things they they're judging perceptually
if you you know if you like see a whole
load of circles of different
size and then you're asked to judge the
size of
the next circle you'll be biased towards
the mean of the
circles that you've already seen it's
called regression to the mean
and in time perception you do exactly
the same if you
if you experience a load of different
durations let's say just beeps of
different lengths and you're judging
the duration of each beep you'll be
biased towards the mean
um and this is a very useful
signature that there's something like
bayesian inference going on here that
you are
your perceptual judgment about a
situation
is based not only on the sensory data
but on your prior expectations
about what's going on bayesian inference
is simply this way of combining what you
already know
with what new information you have to
come up with the best guess when you say
that
we're biased toward the mean do you mean
that of what we experience first so it's
like we take a sample of our first
experience and take the mean of that and
then our later experiences or then bias
toward that mean
or do you mean we're biased toward the
totality of the experiences means
uh well this is a this is a good
empirical question right we
it might depend so
it's it it probably depends on the
details of the experiment over what time
scale the brain is taking the mean um
and it's gonna it's gonna vary by task
by by context and and so on
um in this case i was really talking
about
fairly short time scales where you can
show that you're just on the last one or
two minutes of what's going on then
you'll be biased
in your next decision uh towards the
mean of that
but then you could make the argument
although it's much harder to demonstrate
empirically
that for instance maybe my experience of
duration in general is biased by the
mean of every experience that i've had
and my ancestors have had and so on
but of course i can't manipulate that in
the lab so in the lab i can only
manipulate
context over relatively short time
scales and see what the effect
is but but sorry
when this is very yes circuitous route
to this idea
of of time slowing down and
um so
firstly for me there's a very
interesting distinction here
between perception of duration
and the experience of the flow of time
that's interesting so there's a
difference between those two
yeah i think there is it's
you know we can perceive something as
lasting a certain duration
but the experience of just how fast time
is going
is different um it's different in this
again in perception in general we can
separate
the change of perception from the
perception of change
so i can experience my perceptions
having changed but then the experience
of the change is itself
a kind of perception there are various
phenomena things like
change blindness which show this very
nicely that
it's something if i'm watching a just
like a an image which i'm assuming is
not changing
but actually maybe the background color
changes very slowly
you'll find that people won't notice
that change
and sometimes say people say there's a
paradox here because
they didn't notice that change but
they're now looking at a
different thing so how does that work
and i think that the resolution is to
say well
their perception has changed but they
didn't perceive the change because
change of perception is not the same as
perception of change
so i think the similar thing plays out
in time as well the perception of
duration is not the same thing as the
perceiving time flowing um
and it's much harder to to get an
empirical handle
on the flow of time my favorite
experiment here i don't know if you've
come across is by
uh a guy called david eagleman and and
chess statson i think was his
researcher at the time and so they
they had this idea that if indeed
my perception of time is slowing down at
moments of high
arousal so let's go back to that how can
i test that well
so they had they sort of thought well if
if time is
slowing down then maybe if i do have
some sort of
internal clock that's the ticking of
which is
underwriting this perception then maybe
there are more ticks of the clock
going on in a particular objective
duration
so then i would experience time as
dilated
and so that was the reasoning and so to
test it he had this
beautiful experiment he gave people
watches that were specially designed
so they would flash numbers but so
quickly that if you just looked at them
now
you just see a blur you wouldn't be able
to decipher what
the numbers or the letters were and so
he then had people bungee jump while
looking at this watch
several times then going to crane
look at the watch and and the hypothesis
was well if uh if subjective time is
slowing down
because an inner clock is increasing its
its
rate is frame rate let's say then
maybe these people should be able to
read what's being
reported back yeah yeah what do you
think happened
i would imagine they did right no they
didn't
no it was okay it was a really
interesting failed experiment i mean it
wasn't failed because it
came it was the evidence was pretty
clear
uh but it was it sort of ruled out that
simple explanation that yeah this clock
is speeding up because people you know
subjectively still had an experienced
dilation of time but it didn't seem to
be due to this
acceleration of an internal clock and of
course i think the reason for that
following my colleague warwick is that
because there isn't an internal clock
so that's super interesting to me
because to me it sounds like what you're
saying is we can be wrong about our own
perceptions
for example okay or i'm posing this as a
question
can i say i see this cup as red i see
sorry let's look at this i see this as
blue
okay i see this cup is red i'm sorry i
see this cup is blue
could i be wrong about my own
perceptions i think i see it as blue
but is it possible like in the example
of these people who say that time has
slowed down
but they're wrong about that can i be
wrong about seeing this
now in fact you know with their shared
reality this you can may be able to
objectively measure it as blue
can i be wrong about my perceptions
i think there's two very at least two
very interesting responses to that
um philosophers often talk about the
ineffability
of of conscious experiences that this
idea that
we can't be wrong you know if if i'm in
if i'm in sharp pain now
that's just a fact and
i can't be wrong about it there's
when i think about claims like that the
first thing is
one problem is a sort of epistemological
problem like how would you know
when the claim is about a subjective
experience what's the right way to
validate that
against so does it even make sense as a
question being wrong about your
your own experience um
but what might it mean it might mean
that you are wrong in your
interpretation
about it and i think that's usually what
people
mean when they say that they're wrong
about their
perception um
they
they might say that for instance i
experienced time as slowing down but
then if you actually look at
how they estimated the duration of
something
it may be basically the same
as in another case so
they are you know
right in the sense that they're giving a
a
sort of face validity you know what
they're experiencing
but all the ways one might interpret
that
might might be wrong take another
another very i think
illustrative example um
people for thousands of years have
reported out of body experiences they'll
have experiences where they're
floating above their physical body or
floating around a roof or going
out the window whatever
are they wrong about their experiences
well in one sense
no you know if if that's the experience
they're having
um and they're not just sort of
confabulating it later on
then that's the experience they're
having
but if they interpret that experience as
evidence that their self has in fact
left their skull and gone flying around
then they're wrong that that's not the
right way to interpret those kinds of
experiences
or rather there are plenty of other
options to by which you might
interpret those kinds of experiences and
you can also be wrong
just in the small space that's open
opens up between the moment of your
experience
and the moment of your report and
if i tell you what i'm experiencing i
have to
i have to remember it even if it's only
for a very short time
and you could be misremembering you can
systematically misremember stuff
um there are
yeah there are many ways where we can
introduce
introduce indirectness between your
experience and your report of that
experience so you can be wrong
in that sense too i think
but there is some there is something for
me that that
it almost doesn't make sense to ask the
question can i be wrong about my
experience in the here and now
bracketing all these things about
interpretation and report
because there's no criteria to judge it
against apart from the experience itself
mm-hmm yeah for us if if i may because
and this is one of the questions i had
in mind which ties really nicely into
this
um you most likely know about um jill
both taylor's
famous ted talk the stroke of insight
the one
where she goes into detail about her
experience of having a
hemorrhagic stroke on the left side of
her brain and then she experiences these
feelings of
euphoria and she goes into the state of
nirvana because
the way she's describing it she thinks
her the right side of her brain is sort
of
taking over and then once
her left brain comes back again then
suddenly she she comes back to
her version of the version of reality
that that we experience and she realizes
okay something's wrong i have to go get
some help
and well that talk generally was really
fascinating to me but
i just wanted to know your thoughts on
on that kind of experience
and and and maybe we can follow up with
the idea of
um from a neuroscientific perspective
the left and right brain
uh dichotomy that is created and the way
she describes it
now her talk was 12 years ago or i think
was around 2008
and maybe since then have we had any
advancements any any new discoveries
that sort of shed light on the
on the differences between these two
well i suppose my question is twofold
one is what are your thoughts on on the
on the way she was describing
that out-of-body experience in a way you
could call it an out-of-body experience
and and secondly the distinction between
left and right brain
yeah i mean i i don't have i miss i
don't have too much to say about the
first one about the sort of experience
of bliss or nirvana or
so it's um
you know people again people will do
report these kinds of experiences in
in various conditions there are there
are examples
what comes to my mind are these examples
of so-called ecstatic seizures
so some people with with epilepsy
uh experience reliably
these moments of bliss and awe and
presence
of the numinous and all sorts of
wonderful experiences um either
in the in the penumbra or the periphery
of their seizures or maybe even during
the season
i'm not entirely sure to the extent that
sometimes they
[Music]
would they don't want to be medicated if
they don't they don't want this
to be relieved from their seizures
because they get
this from them quite what's going on for
these sorts of experiences
is extremely hard to say i think and the
part of the problem is
it's been extremely difficult to
investigate them and
investigate them in controlled
conditions uh in the lab where you can
actually see okay this is
this is what's going on is it you know a
wash of a particular kind of
neurochemical or
activity in this or that part of the
brain it's unclear so
some of these stuff from epilepsy is it
shows that
some brain regions seem to be more
implicated than others but but i
wouldn't
i wouldn't want to put too much
stock in those but it's a fascinating
class of
experience sure and i think again
there's a lot of
certainly a lot of interest and there
has been a lot of activity for ages
about the neuroscience of meditative
experiences
and it doesn't have quite the same
endpoint but
that certainly there are there are
examples of people in
meditative states who will experience
the dissolution of the cell from the ego
and
um and so it's kind of fascinating to
see
back to where we started so what in the
brain can explain that kind of
phenomenology
kind of dissolutions
an open question the second
thing about laterality in the brain left
versus right hemisphere and this is it's
a huge
it's uh as other thing most people will
know
we hear these tropes and these cultural
tropes about the left brain being
analytical
and the right brain being holistic and
artistic and left-bringing
and as with all these things
there's a grain of truth underlyingness
but it's only a grain
and um pretty much for everything you do
the both hemispheres of the brain are
working together
some things are more lateralized than
others and so this is
a few of these saying a couple of these
things when you get more towards
output and input things tend to get more
lateralized so if you have a stroke in
one half of your visual cortex that will
affect one half of your visual field
right if you have what a stroke in your
right hemisphere you will be
motor hemisphere your motor cortex will
be paralyzed on your left hand side
so these things are very lateralized um
and that's not to be mysterious thing to
say
then when you get into sort of more
less obviously lateralizable things then
language seems to be basically the only
thing that's reliably lateralized in
terms of brain function in
in humans which is usually on the left
but but not always
so most of the time it's it's it's
working together
i think the the super interesting
studies here
yeah so why i don't really like very
much decide this habit of
describing people as left-brained or
right-brained and you know i think
that's some kind of neo-phrenology
stuff but
what's still really interesting are
these
these old case series these
neurosurgical case series of people with
what we
call callistotomies these are people
who've had split brain operations
um this used to be done
uh it's pretty rare now because other
medications become more effective but
for people with really really severe and
intractable epilepsy
one of the options was to cut all the
well the majority of the fibers
connecting the two hemispheres hence the
term split brain
and there's some absolutely fascinating
observations this goes back to
people like mike gazaniger and joe bogan
someone who would
uh you should give the two hemispheres
different input
to try and ask the question are there
are there two separate conscious
subjects
now um now that you split the brain
like this and there are
very suggestive hints that there's
something weird going on like you can
you can show uh you have to always get
my left right mixed up because so many
things cross over here it's very hard to
keep
keep straight about it but if if i show
my hold on this has to be my right
visual uh
right don't forget about your questions
okay so if yeah anyway if
if information engages the right visual
cortex that doesn't get into my left
then typically the person does not is
not able to verbally
say what that is because the left
language side doesn't have access uh
but we'll maybe try to confabulate
what's going on
so the right hand side might still be
able to draw what they see and then the
left hand side
will make up some story to justify why
the right hand is drawn it and so these
are these are really really super
suggestive but it's still never been
entirely clear
this basic question of are there two
have you have you divided one person
into two or not
because a lot of the early studies
turned out to have been methodologically
limited in various ways and
and so now with sort of more modern
methods
in the few patients that are still
around perception does seem to be more
integrated
across the visual fields than we would
have thought but but to me it's still a
fascinating
case about could we divide a single
conscious person into two conscious
people
and what would it what would it be like
to be one or other half
yeah so so just just to clarify one
point then about it the idea that for
example the right brain
uh as i mean she was describing this way
where she sort of
when the right brain was coming into
into effect she was
she felt like she was connected to
everything around her she no longer felt
like an individual she felt like she she
was
everything and she describes it as the
we
we sort of experience and then when the
left side comes back in
that's where the individual self comes
back on
now this definitely sounds like a really
interesting analogy dichotomy that sort
of thing but i just was wondering from a
neuroscientific perspective how much
truth uh um exists here and
and whether we have any evidence of this
i versus we
sort of distinction well i think there's
certainly
there there is a distinction between uh
or rather the experience of being as an
individual
separate from others and from the world
is something that varies and you know it
varies
for each of us at times if you're
fully immersed in something you tend to
experience yourself as less separate
from him and
people call this sometimes by the by the
term flow experience
um if you're in a crowd dancing or a
football game
the crowd you feel
part of the crowd and that's not just a
metaphor it picks out
i think a valid aspect of your
experience of reduced individuality
at that time people on lsd
that's also one of the classic uh
reports from psychedelic experiences is
a dissolution of the ego
um right and a feeling of connectedness
not now not just with other people but
with the
with nature with the world um
and
so that and all these things together
suggest that well there's a brain basis
for
the strength of our experience of
individuality
and um but i don't think it comes down
to simply right
right brain versus the brain that's all
i see
and just just so that i can go back to
one of your other statements that i
found
really interesting you you mentioned if
i'm please correct me if i'm wrong you
mentioned that
uh an object would exist regardless of
whether we perceive it or not and i
believe i believe that's what you said
i'm wondering how this ties to the i to
john wheeler's ideas
regarding for example he makes he makes
an assertion in the sense that
a conscious observer is a necessity
in order for us to declare that
something exists
without the conscious observer it's like
part of a formula that without it if we
remove it
we cannot make any claims whatsoever
about whether something exists or not
so how does how does the idea that you
brought up tie into that do you agree or
disagree with that
with that well you said two separate
things there which were different so one
is what are the conditions for something
to exist and what
and the other was what are our
conditions for us making claims that
something exists and i think if we
if it's the second then observer is
probably needed you don't make you
you can't make an inference about an
existence without
an inferior but but whether there are
objects
whether object hood or
intrinsically requires observer that
that's again that's
it i think that's a it's a deeply
physical metaphysical question so john
wheeler who you mentioned
is i mean i always associate him with
this idea of
of giving information
some real state of some ontological
status he's famous for the slogan it
from bit
that everything that we
measure whether it's using the tools of
science and physics or
experience fundamentally
our universe is is written in the
language of information
um and
then you know from that then there's all
sorts of
ways of understanding that that kind of
claim because
some sorts of informational
relationships are fundamentally
relative shannon information you think
of that way
it's a sort of uh depends on a sender
and a receiver
um other ways of thinking
uh don't but to me that that's that's
now
that's the sort of i'm not trying to
dismiss the interest of anything i think
they're fascinating and actually they do
play into how we might
read certain contemporary theories and
consciousness science in particular
things like integrated information
theory
from julio to noni then it makes a big
difference what you think information
is um what do you think it's if you
would
or not uh but for the most part i don't
think what i was saying about objects
you know i i want to bracket those
discussions away from from that
um and
maybe yeah it may be true that that in
some
physics-based way that we can't say
anything exists
unless there's an observer but but
for the story i'm trying to tell which
is just this idea that
what we perceive is is always a
construction
but underlying that construction
there are hidden causes that we can
never directly
have access to i think that stands
whatever you think about the ontological
status of information
right you're just looking at it at a
different level in a way these are
distinct levels that
might make sense on one aspect but not
on the other that makes sense
what are your views on the zapr sapir
wharf hypothesis
now it really does feel like an
interview like bang bang one half
question another
um oh and just okay you can gather your
thoughts on that just as an aside
because this bothers me
i'm not a theoretical physicist but my
background is in theoretical physics
when people make claims of consciousness
being associated with the
observer and quantum mechanics much of
that is over exaggerated
and taken up by the new age community
because
they tend to like to use the word
consciousness and tend to
want it to have some ontological
foundational status and it might be
that might actually be the case but it's
over exaggerated and it's extremely
contentious
and i believe something like 90 percent
of physicists don't believe that to be
the case
the wave function can collapse when
there's a another electron or another
set of electrons
let's say objective quality like atoms
observing another photon then you can
collapse the photon
and but even that's a bit that's a bit
that has to be stated more technically
because there's something called
coherence and coherence
either way take those claims that the
conscious observer is necessary for the
collapse of a wave function
with a grain of salt absolutely and
you guys gonna know much more about
physics i mean i started off in physics
but i
i switched to psychology when physics
became too hard i i'm sorry i'm super
interested in your background man
because you also went back to do
a computer science master's and an
artificial intelligence phd if i'm
if i'm correct yeah that's right yeah
yeah okay that's that's super cool well
we'll talk about that after so let's
talk about sapir wharf
okay so sapo-warf hypothesis is really
is this idea
that language either determines or
shapes perception
that um
that the linguistic
environment we live in influences
the perceptual environment that we live
in i think is probably one way to say
technically people will talk about
cognitive penetrability here
that that um is the way we
see the world or hear it or smell it is
that
invaded by higher level beliefs
or cognitive processes of which language
is exemplary
so the sapphire wolf hypothesis is that
yes that um
the the language that we use shapes
the way we perceive it and and this can
be you know this can be in kind of
sort of subtle ways like um
how do i perceive time is that dependent
on the
the way i use language there are there
are all sorts of
lots of interesting anthropological
experiments
looking for languages where for instance
uh
in western languages we tend to think of
the the
uh future as ahead of us and the pastors
behind us
but i think it's the imara there's this
is something i was from
very second hand on but i but there's a
reports of some indigenous south
american cultures
for which it's the other way around
languages for which the other way around
that the past
is uh ahead of you and the future's
behind you the reason being
kind of makes sense to me is that well
you know you can see
the past you know i know what happened
in the past it's happened so therefore
it's
within my line of sight but the future
is unknown i don't know what's going to
happen so i can't see it so it's behind
me
uh so these but with that linguistic
difference that sort of metaphorically
shapes how we talk about time but might
actually influence the way we perceive
time
um so there are all sorts of interesting
questions
about how deep these influences might go
uh to me it's
sort of a priority that
and i'd be surprised if the sapphire
hypothesis
is not true right that's why people
seem to find it appealing i think is
because of this
this idea that there's this modularity
in the brain
that that we have perception which is
some sort of
encapsulated at some lower level we form
this perceptual representation of the
world
and then we think about it and we talk
about it and we make decisions about it
and then we go and
we do stuff we make a plan for what i'm
going to do next we do stuff and then we
perceive the world again
but the brain doesn't work like that i
don't think and and
what you were describing was a bottom-up
approach well
it's sort of more just an approach of of
extreme modularity so people like jerry
fodor is known for
for this view that you know that one of
the longest-running arguments in
neuroscience has always been about
functional localization to what extent
are different things the brain does
localize different brain regions
um and the pendulum has swung back and
forth on this obviously both extremes
can be ruled out to start with you can't
have a brain where
bits different bits do different things
and don't talk to any other bits
um and you can there would be no point
to that because you'd have no
cross-communication anyway right exactly
and you can almost
equally rule out the other extreme
although you can't quite rule out
conceptually but
certainly um empirically it's ruled out
very quickly you have damage different
bits of the brain different things go
wrong
and but you can still but there's still
you know more subtle level there's still
this argument about the degree to which
functions let's say a function like
language
is is just served by
a particular network or brain region
and so those bits of the brain do
language yes they talk to other bits of
the brain
but they don't sort of bleed over into
those other bits
so computers like this laptop computer
is kind of modular in this way that you
know there's a chip that does memory a
chip that's the cpu
uh chip that's the i o ports and so on
um
you can replace these somewhat
interchangeably so it's pretty modular
that so
this kind of design is a reasonable way
to design
systems many of our technologies design
this way
but typically biological systems don't
end up being designed this way
and if we look now that we know a bit
more about
how things like visual perception unfold
in the brain
they're not limited to just the visual
cortex
so the way i and many others think about
perception is that you know it's this
hierarchical set of predictions about
the causes of sensory inputs
many of these happen in visual cortex
but some of them happen
outside of visual cortex so
things like language
will interact with visual cortex
in interpreting coming to the best guess
of the causes of sensory inputs
and there's you know there's a lot of
experiments now there's a
great paper by gary lupin i think he's
at university of madison wisconsin
he sort of took this debate more into
the realm of of experiment and just
summarize a load of evidence showing
that words influence perception
in in pretty clear
ways so this to me is not surprising but
it's also there's just
there's lots of interesting questions
about how far this goes again this is
always the question how deep do these
influences go what kinds of things
are are amenable uh or influenceable
by things like language it seems like
there's a controversy around it when you
even just look at the wikipedia article
about the sapir warf hypothesis pinker
and chomsky
are both against it being true and i
haven't had a chance to look up their
arguments i'm curious if you could
explain to me as well as the audience
what are chomsky's and to a lesser
extent pinkers
but i'm more interested in chomsky's
arguments against it
yeah i to be honest it's not something
i've studied much
either my feeling is that
i mean trump says chomsky is known for
his ideas about universal grammar i mean
he's he's he's such an interesting
character because he in many ways put
the nail in the coffin of behaviorism
sort of saying that okay you need to
take mental internal mental processes
seriously
and we can't just infer them always just
on the basis of
behaviors we need to we need to
assume some complex internal mechanism
of course he was doing this
in the uh in the domain of language and
saying you can't explain linguistic
behavior purely from a behaviorist
perspective on on what
people say just how quickly human beings
learn language there's just
he would say that there's not enough
information in the stimuli that babies
are exposed to for them to
infer grammar and people still will
argue about that you know they'll say
well actually there is and
it just depends on because they're
interacting with it and so
i i'm not a linguist so i don't want to
come down on
one side or other there but in chomsky's
view became this idea of this sort of
language acquisition device this
very very circumscribed
system in the brain that was for
language and so
i think if you take that perspective you
are
you're going to be disinclined to the
sapir wolf hypothesis which is
really motivated by an idea that there
isn't this kind of modularity in the
brain
that things there is to some extent
there's specialization
but there's not a complete kind of
encapsulation
firewalling of one kind of process from
another
is there a difference but sorry going
from yeah it's just when you when you
brought up the idea of the visual
visual cortex being related to other
areas of the brain what that reminded me
of was the
i believe there was a study that they
conducted with regards to
color color detection uh being tied to
uh if if if in the language that that
individual spoke
there was there were there was act there
were actual words that would
define a certain color then
then that individual was capable of
identifying that specific color but if a
language was
was not um it did not have that specific
color um like just it hadn't been
developed in that language and that
person would not be able to to
detect it so i'm just wondering what
this is sort of a piece of evidence
right that yeah i mean that's sort of
connected yeah that's a good
another piece of evidence sort of in
favor of sapi wolf right and
exactly and i think the example that
comes to mind when you talk about that i
think it's russian right and i don't
speak russian but i believe russian has
more words for blue
and um than english maybe maybe
and colors you can test this
really nicely with color because colors
is beautiful example of categorical
perception you have a continuous
wavelength
that you know we typically experience as
a number of discrete colors with with
bits of blurry boundary what happens
when you look at a rainbow i mean that's
what that's what you see
even though the color is the spectrum is
continuously changing
so to assess categorical perception you
sort of ask
you present people with differences on
this continuous scale and ask them to
judge how far apart they are
and if their judgments changes quite a
lot at some times but not other times
then you
then you infer oh there's a category
boundary there um and
so yeah i think i mean this is again for
me it's a bit second hand but
i'm prepared to accept that people who
who learn russian from birth i don't
know about if you learn as a second
language
may divide their experiences of blue
into more categories
than people who have a different
linguistic environment
against me it's like okay this is kind
of fine i don't
unders well for me it shouldn't be a
controversial perspective to adopt
because
this is how perception works in general
we also notice for things like
let's say wine tasting you
initially you all wines or red wines
basically taste the same
um and then as you learn you sort of
learn to distinguish them but then you
learn to apply different labels to
different kinds of wines and then
those help scaffold your ability to
distinguish them still further
what the problem is you've got a chicken
and egg thing here you know what comes
first is it that you
experience things differently and then
label them or can it be the other way
around
and with many of these things i think
it's probably
not a good idea to seek an answer to
that and it's a circular kind of
causality that bootstraps these
differences into existence
do you mind repeating that last part why
is it that you can't start with the
concept and then
be able to perceive that concept
afterwards so for example
i don't know the difference between cyan
and turquoise and
magenta and purple and their cognates do
you know
it just it just looks like blue and some
blue and i know green and red and so on
and i could take 10 seconds to look it
up
and then it probably solves it for the
rest of my life but either way i see
that as bluish green
i see that as purple am i seeing the
same as someone else
but just not noticing and is difference
between seeing and noticing yeah yeah
okay this is good i mean in that
particular case i don't know we'd have
to do experiments to know that right
we'd have to
we what we'd have to do is give these
these different colors
to you and present them in sort of pairs
so you make judgments about how similar
they are to each other
and then we have to see are you making
reliable distinctions
between these colors that you
linguistically describe as the same
compared to somebody who has different
words for these different colors so i
think
these things all boil down to empirical
empirical questions
now here's one test this is this might
not be doable but
imagine you look at a scene and let's
say it has some
discriminable phenomena that are
indistinct at first because you don't
have the
language label for it so cyan and
turquoise for me
for example and you show that to me and
i just oh that's bluish or this blueish
green
then a day later you teach me the
phenomenon of
cyan and turquoise and i'm able to to
discern
then you put me under hypnosis to
remember to remember yesterday
and you say was cyan on the left or the
right
in other words i'm wondering because i
don't notice it initially do i also not
see it does it not get recorded or does
it get recorded
so that i can go back later now with my
proper disambiguations
and disambiguate okay that's interesting
i mean i like the experiment design
apart from the hypnosis bit i think
there's choose whichever method
choose whichever method allows you to
get out of that accurate memory
it's hypnosis is real but it's not what
most people think it is it's not sort of
um it's not this kind of stage
i waver watch in front of you and you
can remember
your child anyway but i think there's
so i can indeed imagine this experiment
where
you make a perceptual judgment
i then give you some prior some
additional knowledge
you make the judgment again and then you
try and you just
try and remember what what you did the
first time and
can you be more accurate uh when you're
retrospectively making your judgment
given now some additional knowledge than
you were at the time i i
met this almost certainly stuff like
that has been done i i don't have it to
the tip of my tongue
but yeah that's that's that's an
interesting uh design that could
certainly
address the question of
well i don't know quite what question it
would it would be
addressing because there's problems
there's many things being conflated here
there's sort of memory
uh along with perception at the time
there's all these things it really
depends
on what the specific question is you're
you're trying to you're trying to ask
but i think it's it's pretty clear
there's lots of you know there are lots
of experiments that show indeed that
expectations what you expect to happen
can directly influence perception
these expectations can be set up by
linguistic phrases so
i think there's lots of good evidence
that what we think what we
um what we say the the structure of
our thoughts and our language can indeed
influence
how we see the world is there
a limitation to the bayesian model of
the brain
i know that it can't be a holistic it
can't explain everything because there's
no con there's no model that explains
everything you'd have the holy grail
right there and i know that you
are a large proponent of the bayesian
model of how the brain works
i'm curious where are its limitations
i'll give you one example from my life
i was playing a video game and someone
in the i was expecting the person
i was expecting the person in the video
game to say the word extinction
and i was i was watching it she said
something and i thought it was
she said entity instead but i was
expecting extinction so then i rewound
it
and she in fact did say extinction so i
thought that was strange
because i expected extinction she said
extinction but i heard entity now these
are rare
but when they come up i do write them
down another one was
i was looking for some object on my desk
let's say it was a pen i don't remember
what it was let's say it was a pen it
was right here
and i didn't do a cursory glance i
looked in it for a second
not half a second but a glance and i
didn't see it and i was expecting to see
it because i'm looking for it and i
looked back and it was right where
i initially looked and so there's
okay there's some sorry okay you
understand the other ones what are the
limits of the bayesian model
it might just okay let's just let's just
take a step back and say
very briefly what the bayesian model is
and so
um you know bay's base theory is just
this way of reasoning with probabilities
it's this idea of
inference to the best explanation
and so in terms of
neuroscience the idea is that
that's what the brain is basically doing
all the time
that perception is
a best guess about the causes of sensory
data it's not a direct readout it's
it's there is sensory data it's
trying to combine prior expectations
about the causes of sensory data with
the sensory data to come up with the
best guess and all of these things are
sort of probabilities
it provides a standard of
optimality bayes theorem in mathematics
and probability theory is really telling
you what the optimal way is
to combine information under conditions
of uncertainty
and so in one sense it's not really
something that can be right or wrong
it's a standard of optimality how how
you use it to think well okay that's
what the brain that's the problem
the brain should be solving if we've got
the
cost function right if we're assuming
the brain is solving the problem you
think it is
it tells you the optimal way to do it
um that's one way to interpret it
another way is more literal to say no
this is actually what the brain is doing
the
the pattern the neural firings the
circuits in the brain
what they're doing are actually the
computations needed to implement
this kind of probabilistic reasoning
that's a much stronger claim
um and
i think that second claim is probably
right but
probably not universally and
this is always across the whole brain
yeah yeah i mean that oh across
well both i mean i think i think in any
given brain
it's probably not sensible to describe
all the things going on in the brain as
involved in
implementing bayesian inference
for the simple reason that some things
can be pretty hard wired and that's one
reason there'll be other reasons too
and one cannot but you still can
probably interpret it as doing
as if it were doing bayesian inference
because you can always tell
a story you can always say oh yeah you
know i can describe these
dynamics as they're compatible with the
brain doing amazing influence but it's a
different question from whether it's
actually doing it okay uh
and again this this is actually a pretty
controversial thing too that that
um
you can find i think there are lots of
there are lots of cases
where
things will look like exceptions to to
this rule
um and they may
well be accepted i mean a tip a very a
very kind of basic example of this
is the phenomenon of adaptation and
perception
uh that for instance if i show you a
load of
a load of lines of that orientation
let's say 45 degrees sloping up
left let's say and then i show you a
line
with a different orientation
you'll perceive it as further away
from what i was showing you before this
is the opposite of the regression to the
mean effect that i was describing
earlier so that so i wasn't being
entirely comprehensive when we were
talking about that
um adaptation
goes away from the mean if you go
towards the mean that's like an example
of
of what you would expect under bayesian
inference because you're expecting that
right so what you perceive
towards that so examples of perceptual
adaptations seem to be
anti-bayesian if you like and so there's
then been a lot of
discussion about
what that what that means i mean it's
just a fact that
that's true i mean that that's what
adaptation does and you can sort of
understand it in terms of different
neural populations getting
fatigued or worn out and so across the
population that's
that's what you see you can still tell a
bayesian story about it i forget what it
is now but um
but there are certainly things that it's
not i don't think the bayesian
brain hypothesis is this sort of
magic solution to every everything
we see but i think it's a very useful
perspective
at that first level about its standard
of optimality and i
also think that a lot of perception in
the brain
and action uh
can is i think probably is
the brain implementing and approximating
bayesian inference the other just last
thing i want to say about that was when
you you were giving your counter
examples of
where you expected to see the pen and
and then it was where you were looking
all along or
you expected to hear a word and
there's a confusion is often made here
because in when people use
base theory to talk about things they
will use words like expectation and
belief and prediction and so on
these are not necessarily
personal level things it's not something
you as a person need to believe
or expect or predict so if i talk about
a bayesian
belief um it makes as much sense to say
that i as a person believe
that neurons are strong landed on the
moon as it would make sense to say
my visual cortex believes that light
always comes from above
it's a belief is a amazing belief is a
probability distribution
so it's not really
it which means that
it could very well be that your brain is
doing bayesian inference even though you
as a person had a expectation that
turned out to be incompatible with what
you see
your visual cortex might be believing
something different let's see
i see can i just interject here a little
bit and
is the bayesian brain model bayesian
brain model in any way
can it be tied to mental disorders like
mood disorders let's say severe
depression
uh because you know when we discuss
ideas such as optimal
you know optimal conditions well someone
who is who's severely depressed
clearly they're not in an optimal
condition can
can the bayesian model sort of identify
what what is going wrong here and
perhaps alter even alter
that sub-optimal conscious experience
any studies on that well let's first be
careful because i don't want to
to imply that uh
sort of i mean clearly being depressed
for instance
is is not a great state to be in so it's
sub-optimal for the person in terms of
their lived experience
but i would worry a little bit about
about sort of saying that there is a
standard of
optimal performance of the brain and
then deviations from that are
wrong and to be avoided um
optimality here simply means
a sort of mathematical optimality about
the most rational way of combining
sources of information that are
uncertain
it can very well be that
being perfectly optimal in that way is
psychologically sub-optimal in fact
many people would argue that that
that we have better psychological lives
and perform better if we're
if we are uh slightly irrationally
optimistic about things
um so so these two things can come apart
and there's this i think there is this
general
worry i have this worry about this this
sort of raiification of things like
optimality from one language to another
and we suddenly start making claims
about people's psychological lives and
ethics and morals and things like that
there's a big gap
having said that you're you're
absolutely right that this is a good
framework for thinking about
phenomena in psychiatric condition
mental illness
other things too perhaps the best
example one of the oldest
is in schizophrenia and psychosis
when we go back to hallucinations what
is a hallucination
in the language we've been talking about
now hallucination can be
usefully thought of as
a a bayesian inference where
your prior belief or your visual cortex
is prior belief
is unusually strong so it's overwhelming
the sensory data so the conclusion the
brain comes to
is guided more by what the brain expects
is there than
what the physical signals from the world
are are saying um if you think that
every perception is this balance between
what we expect and what we get again we
had this example earlier of looking at
faces and clouds everybody sort of has a
minor hallucination
going on there partly because our brain
comes pre-loaded with expectations to
see faces
everywhere faces a very important
stimuli for us as human beings
so we see faces in clouds quite quite
easily
when people are having hallucinations in
well perhaps in psychedelia but also in
psychosis you can think of that then as
again
their perceptual predictions are
overwhelming the sensory data
and i think this is this is a really
powerful approach it's it's
um paul fletcher and cambridge and chris
fritton london
pioneered this this way of thinking many
years ago and
and now people like phil call it yale
taking it
further because it makes very specific
predictions if
somebody with with psychosis
is if their symptoms are explained by
this imbalance then you could presumably
put them into a very
limited uh psychophysical situation
where we can test in a very if you like
boring way
uh what the balance is between their
their expectations and their perception
you know we can we can basically just
and there's this experiment phil call it
did um
was to just associate a
uh a dim flash of light with a noise
but then it very occasionally leave the
flash of light out
and then ask people what they perceived
and people with psychosis would perceive
the flash of light
report the flash of light more often
when it wasn't there than people without
psychosis because
you know the interpretation being
they're expecting the flash of light and
that expectation
stronger in these people so it actually
generates the experience
more often and i really like this
because
it if you think about how
medicine works
you want to get away from
defining conditions purely based on the
symptoms that people report
and you want to get towards
understanding what the underlying
mechanisms are
if it used to be people would have fever
and that would be their disease you know
they have fever and maybe a yellow fever
or another fever
but that was it um and you treat it by i
don't know bloodletting or something
uh but once you understood that
fever is a symptom but there's a
mechanism that's giving your eyes to
that fever and that's an infection
you treat the infection fever goes away
um medicine has always progressed like
that from getting underneath the surface
level symptom description to what what
the underlying pathology is
and in psychiatry this is still early
days
if you look at the diagnostic
statistical manual in psychiatry
it's basically a big list of symptoms um
and depending on what cluster of
symptoms you have
that's what you got
but we're beginning to move beyond that
now this is one example okay
something like psychosis one of the
underlying abnormalities
or aberrant processes is
bayesian belief updating in the brain
and that explains the symptoms
but it also means well maybe there are
more targeted ways to develop
prognosis or therapy even
and so i think this is this is the whole
area which we which is now called by
computational psychiatry coming up with
computational models of the symptoms in
psychiatrics and
conditions so psychosis schizophrenia is
one
but then people also thinking about this
in terms of things like
depression as well and also things which
which i would
rather label as neurodiversity rather
than psychiatric disorders but things
like autism so
conditions um that are not
psychiatric problems but certainly
involve people having different kinds of
experiences
again what's actually underlying the
surface level
uh phenomena here i can see how
depression and psychosis might be
related to
a miscalibration of the bayesian priors
how what about other psychiatric
conditions like you mentioned autism
that one i don't see how it's a it's a
mistake in in how they're viewing the
world it
it seems to me to be more hardwired well
this is going to be clear that i i'm not
i don't think it should be described as
a psychiatric condition autism i think
it's
you know it's it's a it's an example of
diet neurodiversity and um
[Music]
so it's again i think it is a
a very interesting example though
because
typically when people are are given the
diagnosis or label of autism or being
autism spectrum
it's often when some social difficulties
become apparent
and so people typically have thought of
it in terms of an issue with theory of
mind
that um there's a there's a difference
in autistic people about
the way in which they perceive the
states of other people's minds
um and
that's you know that's been for for a
long time
sort of the general understanding of
what autism is
but then if you look more carefully
closely and people have always done this
because about what um
what people with autism report about
their lived experience it's not just
about
theory of mind or anything like that
there are some very basic perceptual
phenomena happening too um
there's often this sensation of being
overwhelmed by sensory data
everything seems overwhelming in the
sensory world loud noises are very
disturbing
um there's a sort of need to control
to make inputs more predictable things
seem more unpredictable
and to me this this and to others this
begins to speak to
something going on that can be more
usefully articulated in a sort of
bayesian language here
are brains of autistic people they're
dealing with uncertainty in a different
way
they're not adapting to changing
probabilities
quite so well um does this sort of
there's there's a lot of hypotheses out
there
the basic point is that
we can again go much deeper
than how these conditions
superficially present themselves to
understand well there's something more
basic going on about how these brains
are processing sensory information
that then these high level phenomena are
built upon
and again back to schizophrenia actually
a lot of the symptoms of schizophrenia
become clinically relevant when they
when they become delusions when people
start having false beliefs
about paranoia and um being controlled
by the cia or something like that
but these false beliefs can be
understood as
higher order inferences to explain away
unusual perceptions
and so it's the perception that comes
first not the belief and you
so you understand begin to understand
that
the primary pathology in something like
schizophrenia is a difficult is a
alteration in perceptual ability
and that only then later on as the
condition progresses
does that uh does that become
manifest in beliefs in different kinds
of beliefs
speaking of well not speaking of let's
take a tangent
girdles and completeness theorem i'm
curious to know what you see as the
applicability or non-applicability of it
with regard to how the brain operates so
someone like penrose or lucas would say
that
it implies that the brain is not purely
computational in the way that we imagine
computation
let's say in a touring sense because of
so and so i'm sure you know the argument
what do you
what do you see as what does girdles and
completeness theorem has i don't think
it has that much relevance to it to be
honest um
i i read i remember reading penrose's
book
the emperor's new mind uh about
well 30 years ago now i think shortly
after it came out just at the beginning
of
when i was just about to go to college
um
waiting for this enlightenment about why
it was gonna be relevant
and um and it's clearly a very
important piece of mathematical
philosophy right
it's telling us that that there are
axioms with any given formal system that
cannot be proven to be true within
that formal system um
and as i understand it was a sort of big
blow against the hilbert program of
trying to bring closure to the
to mathematical explanations uh
and but
quite what that has to say about the
brain
i've never been convinced that it has
that much to say
um and this is partly because
you know i don't think the brain is a
computer
and so the fact that
okay what do you mean when you say that
because clearly well again well not
clearly really
it's sort of yeah i mean it does get a
bit complicated because you know firstly
quite what it is like well what quite
what exactly is good at
saying it seems to be because of course
the
touring class of computation is
something where there is there is
closure
um and
so i guess for me goodal
girdle's theorem
if you apply it to the brain
it may tell you that
the brain is not a computer
um on the reasoning that
there are things that we
can understand to be true
within a formal system that where proof
where a proof of that doesn't
necessarily exist
um this is going way back because it's
been a long time so i thought of this
thought about this but firstly that
doesn't seem
that surprising because even if the
brain were
a computer a computer of this so we
don't know quite exactly what kind of
computer it is so we don't
quite know what sorts of
true statements should be not
establishable
by the kind of computer that the brain
might happen to be
um but i'm
basically i'm kind of happy with the
with the idea that
that uh the brain
cannot be it is not a
does not operate according to these
principles of logic
you know that it's not it doesn't reach
true conclusions about truth by
uh combining these logical operations in
in a particular way
that that good old syrian wrestle i mean
goodall's theorem is a
sort of reduction i think isn't it i
mean it's a real
um strong form of of logic
uh that's does that put you at odds with
some of your colleagues because as far
as i understand most of them
believe that the brain is some
computational device that could be wrong
could just have a bias set
no i think you're right i think that i
don't know if it sets at odds but but i
that well i mean firstly i don't think
it particularly
the whole point about goodell's theorem
for penrose is then made a
claim about consciousness yeah and that
was a connection that was to be honest
never very clear to me
and sort of the idea that that you know
we consciously experience things
that as being true or false
that we know cannot be proved proven
that way
by a system of logic through goodwill's
theorem so therefore consciousness is
not
a property of these kinds of formal
systems
again fine right still might be the case
that the brain does do some information
processing it still might be the case
that that
that it is just uh
um of a you know a constrained or
restricted kind
so you can you can i think you can have
that you can accept that the brain is an
information processing device
but maybe it doesn't have the kind of
class of universality for which good
else theorem becomes
relevant um not all computers have to be
universal
and but i do also
worry that people use that language too
loosely when they talk about
the brain it's a very easy thing to say
that the brain processes information
and that consciousness is a form of
information processing of some sort that
we just don't quite understand yet
maybe but um you know it speaks to mind
uploading
well yeah i mean it's it's
to be honest i think there's this
it's quite a big assumption that
consciousness
is to do with information processing and
the brain is actually an organ of
information processing yes there is an
indirectness between
how scent what sensory inputs do when
they impact our retinas and our things
and
what the organism as a whole does
you can always apply information
processing metaphorically
you can describe a system from a third
person perspective as processing
information
it's transforming inputs into outputs we
can describe inputs we can describe
outputs
and there's an indirect relation so we
can but is that is that what the brain
is
actually doing is it exchanging symbols
in some way
is it um how is its mechanism actually
working or is it just a very complicated
bunch of levers and pulleys
that look as if it's processing
information um
does that difference make a difference i
think it
does when
you draw these kinds of implications
from it
so as you just mentioned if
you believe that consciousness is a
property of a particular form of
information processing
then you might believe that it doesn't
matter what the substrate of that is
what is the physical mechanism that's
underpinning this information processing
and you're not convinced that it's
substrate independent
no i'm not convinced but i'm again i'm
disappointedly agnostic about it
right i mean i actually i think that um
the only concert the only systems we
know of confident
in that are conscious are biological
systems
um it's difficult to come up with a good
reason why that should be so
you know why why is it why should it be
that consciousness is restricted
to things made out of of neurons
but there's also many other levels of
substrate independence there are things
like well
maybe it doesn't matter quite what the
molecules are you know whether they're
carbon or silicon
but maybe the structure of the mechanism
still matters
so theories like integrated information
theory pick out this middle ground for
integrated information theory
the substrate doesn't matter in the
sense that
silicon is just as good as carbon but
the mechanism does matter
you can't have a feed-forward neural
network
without any recurrency be conscious
it doesn't on that theory that's ruled
out because it's a property of the the
mechanism
so there are many different ways in
which
things other than input output mappings
might turn out to be relevant
and the assumption that none of these
things matter i think is
is a dangerous and weak assumption um
and of course that's the assumption on
which these things like mind uploading a
base that the idea that
it really doesn't matter that if i get
the input output relations right if the
system
is functionally identical
then i'm gonna be conscious in my iphone
i just don't think that's a safe way to
think
speaking of tanoni i understand how psy
can be measured in
let's say toy examples in trivial
somewhat trivial
uh idealized states i think you mean phi
by the way science
very fine is his measure psi is like
some sort of you know hokey stuff
okay that's correct although there may
be a relationship who knows right
okay so let's talk about phi is there a
measure of phi
that you have found in living humans
so phi in general
yeah um they have to have dynamics um
so is there a way of using neural
imaging to
determine the why of someone let's say
the straight answer is yes but it's not
the same phi
that julio would want to measure in his
theory
um there are approximations which i
think you can measure
so phi mathematically
is this measure of
how much information the whole of a
system has
about its evolution over time
than the parts do considered
independently it's sort of a measure of
emergence in this sense you can also
think of it a bit more loosely as a
measure of
combination of integration and
information system is going to have
higher fi
if it can enter more different states
that make a difference for itself
so the information has to be for the
system itself and not for an external
observer
so it has to be integrated in that in
that way
um
now for for giulio tinoni
to really measure phi
there's a problem in that
to quantify the amount of information
the system
is generating by being in a particular
state
technically you need to know all the
possible states the system could have
been in even if it's never been in any
of those states
in practice this is nearly always
impossible to know
and it's impossible because we don't
have a high enough resolution or for
some other reason
well for some other reason i mean even
if you could measure everything
in precise detail there are only certain
systems i think they're ergodic systems
where i forget my physics terminology
now but you know
most systems will never will not unless
you push them in some way
they may not explore all the possible
states they could be in
now only explore a subset of their state
space
and so you've got to push a system in
all possible ways to figure out
what all possible states it could be in
r
and you can't do that just by having
high resolution brain imaging
what you can do if you know let's assume
you've got this fancy new technology you
can you can
measure with arbitrary high arbitrarily
high
spatial and temporal resolution you can
measure now an approximation to find
there's still massive difficulties
computational difficulties in
considering how you cut all these you
know what the right
granularity of time and space is that
gives the maximum value of it and
how you cut the system up to find
where what what partition makes the
biggest difference between the whole and
the parts
they're massive problems but you can do
it and you know with my
colleagues here with adam barrett in
particular
and pedro mediano in london we've been
developing for
nearly 10 years now some approximations
to find
that capture some of the spirit of it
that it's a measure of combined
integration information
but which you can practically apply to
brain imaging data
so that's certainly possible but
it has to be recognized that they are
approximations
and um
and they as of now they don't work
very well uh when we apply them to
actual data in the sense that they
they're pretty insensitive to
or rather that they're very noisy you
can change subtle
things in a system and then the measure
changes quite a lot
so i wouldn't have very much confidence
applying these measures to
empirical data although it's certainly
something we're still working on
i was reading a paper by peter lush a
few months ago
before i had researched you at all turns
out you're a co-author on it so that's
pretty cool
it was about the rubber hand illusion
and imaginative suggestion
demand characteristics and
phenomenological control right exactly
now i don't recall it precisely and i
wasn't sure about the relationship
between the three
as far as i understand demand
characteristics serve as an implicit
imaginative suggestion
and as far as i understand
phenomenological control
is the degree to which you can act on
that suggestion or the degree to which
you can act on your expectation
is this something like that and do you
mind just yeah if you know what should
be
talking about outline it for the
audience because i found it extremely
interesting
yeah this is a switching of years again
but i'm glad you're glad you brought it
up i mean
there's a lot of terminology there in in
in one sense they're all
vaguely unsuccessful attempts to avoid
saying hypnosis because hypnosis has all
this unfortunate historical baggage
i think there was the word
hypnotizability in the paper it'll be in
there but
but you have these these so let's take
them one by one so demand
characteristics is a phenomenon that
psychologists have known about forever
since the 60s at least it was formalized
that but i'm sure people knew about it
before
this is the idea that if you're doing a
psychological experiment
oftentimes your subjects might
implicitly or even explicitly know what
you're trying
to you know what the right answer is so
to speak
and either just
deliberately tell you what you are
expecting to hear because they don't
want to disappoint the experimenter
or unconsciously actually have that sort
of experience if you if you expect
if you if the context of an experiment
is strongly
leading you to have a particular kind of
experience in one condition rather than
another
then you may well have that experience
and so
in psychology it's always been important
to rule out demand characteristics if
you want to say that something else is
responsible
which basically means trying to say that
people don't have
different expectations for different
experimental conditions
and then if you still see a difference
then you can say well it's not because
of
their implicit expectations about what
should happen
um and
then we get to uh
suggestibility imaginative
suggestibility hypnotic suggestibility
these are this speaks to there's a
there's
quite reliable individual differences in
how
hypnotically suggestible people are and
by suggestible here i mean
something like you can be
asked to experience something like a fly
crawling up your arm or something like
that
and you might have you might actually
start to experience that
um you know your hands are being drawn
together there are ways
in which people vary in the extent to
which
a suggestion from a from a third person
can induce an experience that's what we
mean by
hypnotizability here so it's not the
kind of darren
brown big magic stage magic thing that's
fascinating too
it's more like just how how much can
your experience
be influenced by what i say
and people vary a lot in this you're in
there
that's a huge celebrity right he's
brilliant
actually i love listening to his
interviews
i think it's underrated here in at least
in canada in
america but
but so now you can start to see that
if you've got an experiment where
there might be demand characteristics
going on such that the setup of the
experiment
leads you to expect
some sort of experience in one condition
but not another
if you're highly hypnotizable highly
suggestible
the demand characteristics might have a
stronger effect i see
um because they basically act as a
suggestion
and if you're more susceptible to
suggestions they're going to have a
stronger effect
now the third piece is this term
phenomenological control which peter
luschen
and zoltan dienes my other colleague of
sussex they sort of introduced this term
basically to try and
firstly that these suggestions can
affect your experience hence
phenomenological phenomenology
and the idea of control is it's the
subjects you yourself i you know i give
you the suggestion but then you're
controlling you're generating your
experience i can't just even though
you're not aware of doing it
you know that that's the point so
i can reduce you to experience something
if you're highly suggestible
you're generating yourself but you're
not aware that you're doing it it sounds
like the placebo it's related to the
placebo effect it's
very related right again people who
respond to the placebo effects
arguably and there's some evidence that
they're more highly hypnotizable
um they're more suggestible they're
changing their experience in a response
to a suggestion
so there's this very big typically
uncontrolled variable in a lot of
experiments
of hypnotizability traits for
knowledgeable control suggestibility
take your pick and this matters if your
experiment involves demand
characteristics because now the results
you're gonna get will depend on who you
test
and so we've thought this is work led by
peter and
and zoltan and warwick who i mentioned
earlier warwick roseboom who's worked on
the time perception staff too
thought this is what's going on in the
rubber hand illusion the rubber hand
illusion is a very famous thing i
i mention it i demonstrate it in my ted
talk
and i tell the old story so this is
something where i've had to change my
mind about it a little bit
you tell the whole story yeah the pre
phenomenological this is why i wrote
down because
i remember you referencing the rubber
hand illusion plenty and i thought okay
are you using this as a basis for your
model
and i know that there are some holes
that are poked in the rubber hand theory
at least by peter lush so i was like oh
hey yeah that sounds interesting but
then i found out
wait you co-authored that paper so you
should know about this it might be
correct in my interpretation of it
ah no i mean we we're in fact
we're we should change our minds right i
mean if i didn't change my mind about
something i wouldn't be a good scientist
right
so so yeah this is what so that talk was
from 2017
and this work in the rubber hand
illusion started maybe in 2018 or 2019
so um but actually they both fit with
this general story so this rubber hand
illusion is this idea that
my experience of i can i can change my
experience of body ownership
of what is my body in some fairly simple
lab based way if if i put a rubber hand
in front of you
and your real hand is hidden from view
and i stroke the rubber hand
simultaneously with the real hand so
you're seeing stroking on the hand
you're looking at her hands it's a
rubber hand but you're seeing strike and
you're feeling it too because i'm
stroking your real hand
then for some people you start to have
this weird experience that this hand is
somehow part of your body even though
you know it's not
um and so the simple story explanation
for that
is that it's just multi-bayesian
multi-sensory integration that
the brain sees touch and it feels touch
and it's putting these things together
and
decides that's my hand yeah
but there's this other factor which is
that's a situation which is going to
very strongly induce
demand characteristics you're seeing
something looks like a hand and
you're being stroked and then the
experimenter asks you does that feel
like your hand
you can see it's going to set up that
expectation
and so what peter's work beautifully did
was to
show that in fact individual differences
in
imaginative suggestion in suggestibility
correlate with how strong the rubber
hand illusion is i see
and he also showed that typically people
use as a control they stroke the rubber
hand
out of time with a real hand yeah so now
this is going to break this
multi-sensory integration because now
you feel touched but it's no longer
aligned with the touch that you're
seeing
and what happens well people experience
it much less
yeah but the point is people also expect
to experience it much less if you ask
just people what would they expect to
experience when it's out of time
they say well i wouldn't expect to
experience it then so
it's not a good control for demand
characteristics because
what you expect to experience differs
in both cases i'm sorry
i thought that what you did was great
with the pulsing of the heart because i
don't imagine that someone would think
or would even be conscious of how their
heart is pulsing to be able to associate
the one that is in line with okay
does that not show that it's not purely
the demand characteristics or the
imaginative suggestion because you don't
know you don't have access to how your
heart is beating
you do it in some way but you're not
paying so i think i think unfortunately
not in two different ways one way is
that in fact
suggestion effects can influence basic
physiology as well
it's not just limited to what you might
subjectively report about your
experience you can induce
physiological responses through imaging
suggestions
so that's one thing and the other thing
is you know get that experiment again so
i
you know it was i was really and still
am i think it's it's it's a great
experiment that we did at the time
but we did not look for individual
differences
in people's suggestibility this was like
before we did this new work so we did it
a small family the problem is this makes
experiments in this area really hard
because
to peter's experiment where we measured
hypnotizability and then looked at the
rubber hand illusion
we did the experiment or he did the
experiment well a bunch of people did on
i forget was it 430 or 340 hundreds of
people
it's normally these experiments are done
on groups of like 20 or something like
that
um and so
i don't know in that in this experiment
that you're referring to
where what we did was instead of
stroking the hand we gave people a
virtual hand and it flashed
either in time or out of time with their
heartbeat and again we found
that people experienced it more as their
own hand
when the flashing was in time with their
heartbeat so sort of what we called
a cardiovascular cardio
something version of the rubber hand
illusion intercepted version
um i don't know to what extent that's
driven by
suggestibility i just don't know because
we didn't measure it
and so we need to do it again and we
haven't yet
for us i'm also wondering and i'm just
thinking out loud here if if there's any
utility to test
test this experiment when the
participants
are on psychedelics um
in a sense that's a psychedelic question
[Laughter]
i was asked that because you know you
you discuss the level of complexity how
that's
that's um yeah one of your talks you
were discussing how it gets
it's more complex when when these
individuals are on psychedelics versus
the wakeful resting state
yeah so so we've done some work in
combat in collaboration now with the
group at imperial college london led by
robin card harris on
on what happens in the brain during
psychedelics um
and there are lots of dif interesting
differences um
one of the one of the challenges is that
when someone's on a large dose of
psychedelics they can't really do
anything
yeah they can lie they can line a brain
scanner but you can't get them to do
an experiment and press buttons
and report what's going on
so you know one of the things i'm
excited about is the potential for
actually research
in using microdosing here so if you give
people very small doses
sure they don't have the big vivid
hallucinations
any differences in the brain are going
to be correspondingly more subtle
but you have the big advantage that
people can still do experiments
so you know i'd certainly like to i
think that's that's a
very rich vein of work to follow by the
way just to connect those two points
there was there was a lovely paper i
think by olsen and
colleagues from a couple of last year
where they they claim to have induced a
psychological psychedelic experience
through
hypnotic suggestion interesting it's
called like tripping on nothing
and they should set up set up the whole
context have a very nice relaxing lobby
area and
people come in fully believing they're
going to be taking part in some
experiment with suicide and and then
they don't get any
but they're still led to believe that
they have got it and then they often
report
all these hallucinations and things
going on so so
potentially you can even induce
psychedelic
effects given strong enough expectations
about what's going on now of course
i would say there's probably still going
to be a difference between
a placebo psychedelic experience and a
real one
but quite what the difference is is an
interesting open question
what insights have you found from any of
your psychedelic experiences if you can
talk about it that you feel like
were let's say world view shattering
or world view forming um
if anything it was more reassuring
because
the thing is a lot of my
work over the years has been about
trying to understand perception of this
kind of construction
you know this perceptual best guess um
we've been talking about examples of
seeing faces and clouds and all these
effects that
fit very comfortably with this view of
how the brain works and how it does
perception
so you think when you're on psychedelics
you're temporarily shifting with the
bayesian priors
yeah i think so i think it sort of made
sense it sort of makes sense that way
firstly it gives you very very
immediate insight that your perceptual
world is a construction of some sort and
it starts departing from
what it used to be quite quite quickly
and it's interesting people can have
very different i think
take different lessons from experiences
like this
depending on their prior beliefs about
them again so if if people
believe that there's some sort of
it some people might believe that
psychedelics
are evidence for a more immaterial form
of consciousness because
you know you suddenly depart from you
yourself you don't experience yourself
so much and
and so you might think well this just
this is good evidence that that
consciousness is
is not this thing created by my brain
somewhere behind my eyes um
but for me and you also might
reinforce beliefs and things like pan
psychism that consciousness is
everywhere because the whole world seems
to be alive and
vivid with with meaning uh but the other
way to think of it is that
if you come say somebody like me with a
prior belief that the brain is the organ
of that experience
it's just more evidence for that because
you mess with the brain
in a very straightforward way you just
activate these serotonin
receptors and bang your experience of
the world myself massively changes
so i sort of interpret it as very strong
evidence for the material basis
of our conscious lives what do you make
of daniel dennett's claims
of well let's say daniel dennett's view
of consciousness have you read his
explaining consciousness book i always
find it insightful to know how
let's say luminaries like yourself and
others disagree
i mean well bennett is the luminary in
this uh
in this group he's i i
started reading his stuff again at a
reasonably early stage so
in the early 90s i was lucky to to read
it consciousness explained and it's it's
a remarkable book
um and you know i have been a lot
inspired by
dana over the years
and
i agree i think to a large extent but
maybe not
the whole way but
that might partly be because
i found it quite difficult to know what
the whole way actually means
for dan so meaning you're unsure of what
his viewpoints are
well i mean i i've had many
conversations with him and i know
it's it's there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of so i think where
we so one thing that i very much like
about his ideas is this sort of
idea about um multiple drafts and centre
of narrative gravity and
and um this sort of idea that
the self the narrative self this
identity that we have the thoughts
that we think that that it's not some
sort of internal essence of self
there's just many things going on and we
kind of construct our
uh experience of being a continuous self
um
he's also for me anyway bang on about
um some of the mistakes that people make
when they think about perceptual
experience so for instance
you know he's he's he's very much
uh actually i will tell you i'll tell
you one story because he was at the
when i gave my ted talk in 2017
he was in the audience and i was
massively terrified giving this talk
it's a terrifying experience oh you look
calm on stage yeah
it's a totally terrifying experience but
i was most
terrified of the fact that danny was in
the audience and
wondered what he was going to think of
it and
he was very kind and he said it was
almost perfect and then okay what's up
what's the problem he said well you said
and i have like a father figure he said
it's not
precisely the mistake
yeah he wasn't to know about the rubber
hand illusion stuff right that wasn't
mistaken nobody knew about that we
hadn't done the work
i'd said as part of the talk this idea
of
conscious perception as like an inner
movie
that and i can't remember the precise
words i use now i used to know them
totally by heart but um this idea that
i described this multi-modal fully
immersive
in a movie as a description of what
perceptual experience is like
and that's what he said no no he doesn't
like that because it implies there's a
little person in your head viewing it
exactly exactly it implies even though i
didn't mean it and i don't believe it
just that linguistic slip it sort of
it gives that impression it's easy to
interpret that way
and it might speak that i still [ __ ]
had fully hadn't grasped that
point if you speak of it in a movie you
imply
somebody watching the movie no there is
no inner movie right and that just begs
the question but i do recall
um i do recall dennis saying that it's
okay to have a little person inside your
brain watching the movie as long as that
little person has another one and it
doesn't regress
infinitely because each little person
can be different than the last
do you remember this argument not not
really i don't i just think it's easier
to do away with that argument at all you
know there's no need for it
it's a it's a solution for there's no
problem that that
it's a solution to a problem that
doesn't exist why would you need a
an inner homunculus anyway yes we do
have what we can call metacognitive
processes so i can make judgments about
my conscious experiences i can tell you
whether i'm confident or not or i can
tell you whether
um yeah i can reflect on and evaluate
things that happen but that doesn't mean
there's a
sort of inner observer it just means
there are
there are hierarchical organization
of my cognitive architecture
so yeah
so he certainly he's alway i've always
found him
very on point about picking up on errors
like that
where i've never been entirely clear is
these claims about
the extent to which we're mistaken about
what it is we're trying to explain when
we try to explain consciousness
he's often criticized or understood as
saying that
qualia don't exist um
i'm not sure that that's what what he
means i think it's entirely
right to say that qualia these you know
the redness of red the
painfulness of pain are not what we
think they are
but that doesn't necessarily mean they
don't exist
um but yeah i mean he's for me he's he's
definitely
one of the people i still always learn
from every time i
every time i speak to and it's been an
interesting
seeing talking to him and seeing how
he's talking more also in terms of the
bayesian brain these days and trying to
you know put his ideas
within that framework which i think is a
really interesting project
and do you agree with his conception of
uh free will the compatibilist
approach i i'm a compatibilist yeah i
mean i
i think i think free will is another
kind of perceptual experience and i
think this whole
debate about determinism is totally
irrelevant to do
understanding of free will i'm trying to
get right
dennit on the podcast he said that he's
busy writing a book
so he can't come on i'm also trying to
get douglas hofstetter
what are your views on douglas
hofstadter's model
i just don't know i don't know him
personally and i've read only
really the amazing um
um it's one of the best books everybody
everybody should read that
it's phenomenal um it's just playful
what i take from that is just this
incredible playfulness creativity i have
it right here i can keep only it's uh
three books beside me four books one of
them yeah and that's one that's one of
them you know that's that's
i don't know if you know the show the
desert island discs we have it on the
radio here in the uk
and the idea has been going on for like
decades and the idea is you
what are the eight songs that you would
take with you if you're getting banished
to a desert island never to return
you can only take eight tracks um and
then you're also allowed so most people
in england spend half their lives
figuring out what these eight tracks are
going to be just in case they get
invited onto the show at some point and
you want to be ready
um but you're also allowed to take a
book cool
and so for you that would be definitely
well i wouldn't
say it would be the one but it would
certainly be up there i haven't made a
container decision about the book yet
um but it's so i love the way it just
creates it
playfully explores our intuitions about
what cognition is what mind is what
what explanations and biology physics
consist in i think it's i think it's
just he's a genius
sort of insights yeah have you read his
analogy book
i haven't i haven't no it's a great one
but it's
far too long so sometimes it goes
through lists and lists
what i find to be somewhat tedious okay
so what are your views on his views of
consciousness where do you agree
disagree
well that's a tricky question because to
be honest i it's been i
would be hard-pressed to articulate what
they are i mean
to me it got his talks about strange
loops and things like that
um
yeah i don't have i don't have a
particular strong
view because i to me i've always just
associated him with these with these
things about
language recursion all these all these
playful insights so
i don't think he's as far as i know he's
not
coming to my radar specifically about
consciousness more about what's
self-consistent and what we think of as
a self and that's it when you're saying
that
the homunculus it's a it's a foolish
model in some ways
what about global workspace theory as
far as i understand i don't know much
about it i just
had a cursory glance at it it sounds
like there's a homunculus because
there's something that's viewing
or there's a well you can explain it
much better than i but what are you what
are your views on the global workspace
theory
so the global workspace theory is one of
the sort of most popular theories in
consciousness science
neuroscientific theories these days and
it's um
it's first developed by bernie bars and
taken on mainly by standard hey in paris
neuroscientist
and it makes a very simple sort of uh
proposal that
what we are conscious of the contents of
our consciousness
they become conscious in virtue of being
broadcast in this
workspace in the brain that gives them
access
to many different cognitive processes
which is why
i'm conscious of this glass of water
means
i can do many things now in virtue of
being
conscious of it i can drink it i can tip
it over the computer i can take it to
the kitchen
i can put it down again from it
i can talk about it um and so that
uh whatever in my brain is representing
the perception of that glass has access
to all these different
flexible cognitive processes and for
global workspace theory it's that
process
of being available broadcasted around
this
workspace that endows that perception
with the property of being conscious
um the analogy i think is done again
uses the analogy fame in the brain
for that theme in the brain fame in the
brain so something becomes
feminist famous within the brain all
other parts of the brain know about it
suddenly my
my auditory cortex knows about it my
language senders know about it
my motor cordx knows about it it's
famous there's a cup there's a there's a
glass of water
hooray everybody can see it it's famous
yeah
and that fame in the brain underwrites
conscious perception
um so that's that's the claim
the nice thing about it is it explains a
lot of the
functional properties we associate with
consciousness because indeed there are
things i can do when i'm conscious of
something that i can't when i'm not yes
and this flexible action is is central
to that
it's also testable because you can put
people in brain scanners
and change you know present them with
stimuli and
vary whether they're consciously
perceived or not and you can look for is
there this ignition of this global
workspace in the
in the brain when they're conscious and
many experiments would say there is
the issue with it is that
it's not for me explaining a great deal
about
and back where we and as we sort of
begin to wrap up we're back where we
started which is with phenomenology
so the fact that something is famous in
the global workspace
explains a lot about what we can do
behaviorally and functionally
but it doesn't really explain to me at
least well
why is it why is this visual experience
the way it is
the phenomenology of this visual
experience has a character
just being famous in the global
workspace doesn't really explain that
it also is not going to address the hard
problem of consciousness yeah that's
what i'm
thinking no one would no one claim that
it is but there's this often inverse
relationship it has a benefit of being
eminently testable um
and although you know you can finesse
and say well the global work space is
wherever you find it in the brain and
there are problems because
how do i separate the signature of a
workspace being active
from simply my
consciously reporting something has
happened um
maybe the difference i'm seeing in the
brain is just the difference in
my verbal report rather than the
mechanisms that give rise to the
experience
so there are some tough questions there
too but it's
it's uh it's an appealing theory i you
know
i don't focus on it because for me i
want to focus on what kinds of
mechanisms explain phenomenology and for
me the bayesian perspective
is much is much more interesting farraz
why don't you ask a
question to wrap up and then i'll ask my
last question as well
first of all it has been a fascinating
talk thank you so much
for this conversation been great yes i
thought it was going to be half an hour
it was certainly not half an hour yeah
i'm sure our audience our perception of
time has changed
yes just just to wrap things up maybe
very briefly if you could
just let us know maybe do you consider
yourself as someone who
looks at the world through a pragmatic
lens as opposed to let's say maybe an
objectivist
lens because you know i always look at
the world i think there are there are
different
frameworks from which we can we can
choose to to look at the world and
to me the pragmatic approach seems to be
a
the one that is that matches really
nicely with the evolutionary
um evolutionary perspective
so i'm just wondering what your thoughts
are on it's very briefly i know it's
been a long time
do you mean as a as a scientist or as a
sort of person going about my daily life
here
do you think there's a i suppose i
suppose both would be interesting
as a scientist it makes sense that that
you want you might want to take a more
objective
approach but maybe other person could be
uninteresting well i think there's
always a blend right i mean even
as a scientist there's a sort of
objectivity is is an ideal right you
don't
get there and much philosophy of science
emphasizes that
how in practice pragmatic it is you've
got to do experiments
you come up with testable hypotheses and
you don't
have a kind of complete it's not
hypothesis
test ruled out either it's it's sort of
what ideas are more
uh lackintosh talks about experimental
fecundity what framework give rise to
experimental predictions um
and so yeah i think scientifically i'm
quite pragmatic as well
i want to focus on areas
of the problem where progress is
conceivable
which is why you know i don't focus on
coming up with a trying to think up
some eureka solution to the heart
problem of consciousness
i don't i prefer to see if i can get
there by doing stuff that can be done
um and yeah i guess that's
against the answers to say yeah this
question part of your reasoning is that
part of the reason why you dislike the
heart problem just because of its
ostensible interactability
i i don't dislike it at all um you know
i think
i think it just it crystallizes in a
very very
important way uh an intuition
about consciousness and a metaphysical
challenge
for explanations um it's just that i
don't
think addressing it head-on is the most
pragmatic productive
path for consciousness science to follow
okay so um i have quite a few questions
i'm going to list them and then you
could just choose one
whichever one feels like it'll give you
the most bang
give it the most bang for the buck i was
curious you mentioned grainger causality
and i
and you said that it wasn't used often
in neuroscience and i want us to know
why is that the case then okay another
question was
the relationship between consciousness
and intelligence not
the way that intelligence is used when
people say artificial intelligence but
more like iq the neuroscientific iq
and i was curious if there's been any
tests where you give someone anesthesia
how much anesthesia is required is
proportional to the iq of the person
so that is one way of testing is someone
who has a higher intelligence
more conscious in some sense okay so i
was going to ask you okay the one i want
i wanted to know about
your opinion on box theories
there's a slide in your
presentation i believe it was about the
free energy principle and how it relates
to hold on you just pick the one you
want me to ask okay
let's get back to artificial
intelligence because you have a phd in
it
there's different architectures some of
the famous ones like gan
convolutional now yoshibok said that
one of the ways that the gan that the
generative adversarial network relates
to the brain is in dreams
he thinks that dreams are like your
brain testing you at your weakest point
almost like the adversary
test okay so you get the idea now i'm
curious
there's gans there's convolutional
recurrent lstms there's transformer
and boltzmann let's see
that's right are these different
architectures do you see them as related
to different modules in the brain
much like yosha said hey well the gan
might be response
somewhat related to dreams is it like
the convolutional
is how we it's our visual perception and
it's pretty much that
transformer is your ability to generate
dialogue
okay can we pick a different question
okay i'm not kidding i'm kidding let's
go with that
we'll have that one um we'll take it a
little while why is that a difficult
question to answer
it's it's kind of difficult i mean so
yeah my phd in ai was quite some
time ago but but we're actually still
working on in fact working on it more
and more these days again with some
super smart colleagues and grad students
um
and i think for the reason you just
mentioned because
you we have this i think
so it's easy to say
that the brain is making predictions
about the causes of sensory data and
that's what we perceive and
it's doing some sort of baiting
inference so but exactly how it's doing
it
and exactly how you can collect
evidence to test these ideas of exactly
what's going on
depends on having much more
sophisticated computational model
of this process so
which is why i'm very interested in
these different classes of network
what can they explain about perception
and
behavior how well do they map onto what
we know
what we can measure in the brain
um and actually the other way around can
we actually develop
better machine learning architectures
through understanding more about how the
brain
does these sorts of things and there's
good example one of the things we're
working on there is for instance
most convolutional neural networks which
are extremely good at classification
require bucket loads of data one of the
reasons they started to work
is that they can be trained on the
internet
there's huge amounts of data and compute
computation power
um and lots of interesting little tweaks
but you know the principles of deep
networks were there
long before their renaissance
but we learn things
quite quickly we don't need exposure to
everything in order to learn
new concepts and things like that so
we're doing it slightly differently
one of the things that humans and
animals do when they learn is they
select what data to learn from you pay
attention to different things
you forage for data
and so this opens a possibility can we
define can we design more efficient
machine learning algorithms
that gain efficiency through selecting
the data they learn from
um and then how do they know what data
to look for well that's a problem we can
investigate in terms of what humans do
is that related to the frame problem
no not particularly it's it's more i
mean that's really a problem about how
things come to have meaning um
or a single grounding frame well yeah i
guess that's sort of related
um in the sense that this is really a
much more much more
kind of yeah they're related in the
sense that that
basically how much do you need to know
about context and
things to to learn stuff but just very
pragmatically
what's the size of data set that you
need in order to achieve
certain performance and generalization
capacity in a network
so that's one way but the other way i
think is is more interesting from a
perspective what we've been talking
about which is
do any of these classes of of
architecture in ai
do they serve as useful
[Music]
ways to understand what the brain is
actually doing how it might be
actually implementing or approximating
something like
bayesian inference and we'll
finish just with a sort of a simple
line of thinking here which is the still
currently
off-the-shelf networks that people are
still excited about
basically feed forward networks these
deep convolutional neural networks like
alex net cap and nuts and
there are many layers and they're
trained on a lot of data
um but they process it in this kind of
feed forward direction
seems the brain doesn't work like that
at all in fact the whole frameworks that
i've been we've been discussing are more
about
top-down predictions being reigned in by
sensory data they put a lot of emphasis
on the current
top down in inside out connectivity
um and so to model that kind of activity
a feed forward deep convolutional neural
net is not sufficient
so we need to have we need to look at
architectures that have
top-down connectivity that have
generative models and there are
architectures actually
there are architectures there are and
they you know there are generative
networks now
i mean there's a long history of
generative networks they go back to
variational auto encoders and things
like that
um helmholtz machines helmholtz being
the same guy that
is historically associated with
predictive perception and the bayesian
brain um but they became a little bit
less
less worked on because deep networks
became so powerful
so quickly but now there's a lot of
movement back towards the power of
of unsupervised learning of generative
uh
models in networks generative
adversarial networks have one example of
that
um where you know one network will try
and produce examples
uh to fool another network's
classification
um you said that joshua
talks about that as a good model for
dreams indeed it might be there are many
other ways to think about what dreams
might be doing is just sort of pruning
the complexity of a generative model
you let it free run and then you kind of
prune its
parameter space down a bit and and so
there are lots of i think lots of
interesting things
to be explained about perception
cognition and consciousness
through coming up with uh the right kind
of
of machine learning architecture
computational model
and things that involve explicitly
generative components that for me that's
where the action is at the moment
professor thank you so much i'm
definitely going to be following your
work and
many of the people who are listening are
going to follow your work from now
where can people find out more about you
what are you working on next
well thank you thirsty thank you curt
for us that was a
very stimulating conversation um we
could go on for longer but i'm about to
die so i don't think
we can um but thank you for a wonderful
conversation um
thank you if people are not already
completely sick of
stuff that i have to say then um you can
find out more
easiest things on my web page which is
www.anilseth.com
i'll leave a link in the description and
i think as you mentioned at the the top
there's
you know there's a 17 minute version of
all this is the ted talk
which is out there and uh i
am putting the finishing touches to uh
a book um aimed at the informed general
audience so hopefully the kind of
people that would be watching this
listening to this
um the book is called being you a new
science of consciousness
and it all being well will be out
uh sometime between may and september
next year we haven't got a precise
publication date but it's
the plan is to publish it in the middle
of 2021 so
in less than a year and you can sign up
on my website for updates
about that book if that's something
you're interested in
okay everyone go to his website sign up
get notified when he comes out with this
book
follow him on do you have twitter i do
oh yeah yeah that's so you can follow me
on twitter uh
you'll put the link in but it's just
okay seth but yeah you can follow me on
twitter too
thank you again by the way how is it
that you stay so fit do you have a
regimen do you meditate do you
fast um oh i don't know why
why you think i'm i'm i'm that oh well
no i mean actually this
you look healthy one of the could be
wrong for me one of the weird things
about
the the pandemic this year um
is i've not been well not women but none
of us have been traveling
but actually i've been lucky enough not
to
not to come down with it so far
and slightly paradoxically i feel fitter
than i
have normally done because i've been
able to keep a better routine
just interesting don't have jet lag all
the time and i can
build going for a run two or three times
a week properly into the routine so
actually doing uh you know looking after
myself has become a little bit easier
in some ways during this during this
period i find that academics
and people who are more interested in
intellectual domains tend to do well
during this lockdown because they like
to sit and
write and not be disturbed oh yeah
well if only it was like that i mean the
the flip side of that is i mean this has
been a lovely
conversation on zoom but the number of
hours that i spent on zoom time zones
also seem to mean less because i can now
just get wrapped into a meeting in
california and the
great night and australia the next
morning so
7 pm it's just coming up just uh yes
and lastly you went like this when you
said that you don't have covid
do you feel strange as someone who at
least i i would imagine you think of
yourself as a rational person
and this obviously doesn't do anything
but
but it feels right and it feels like if
you don't do this
something bad may happen so how does
that comport with how you see
a really yourself question to finish you
know
yeah i mean it's it's it's still true we
we still have these
i mean partly it's a social signal right
i just i just wanted to do that
to indicate to them to avoid having to
say that
fortunately so far i have been able to
avoid it's just it's kind of just a
gestural shortcut but still you know
academic understanding does not trump
our lived experience all the time
i still see colors as really existing in
the world
even though i know they are
constructions of the brain
so the way we the way
the study of consciousness changes me as
a person is that everything changes but
everything stays the same to you
it's great it's a great talk thank you
so much thank you i look forward to your
to reading your book professor yes i'm
gonna do it hopefully
on vacation if it's next summer after a
long time that should be great get some
rest man okay thank you
you